hi all
um
hi chris uh
so we're going to use the
the twitch stream method um hopefully
less adverts this time for this final
game of the world championship
which was uh
the final classical
time control game
uh game 12 was today
um can you see the board chris
no i'm not yet okay i still have the cat
and mouse picture all right um hopefully
we'll get chris
viewing this board
in
a few seconds
um
so
it was a 12-game match and it was the
12th game today so we're gonna enter oh
sorry i'm not going to say the result of
the game
i don't want to spoil the result of the
game sorry so you might not know the
result of the game
you already you already did this in a
way but no no no we can't spell the
result of the no no it's a mystery yes
let's let's see no no keep it a mystery
yeah um
but um
so anand was playing white
and
played
e4
and um
okay
uh
any any news on the chessboard yet chris
yeah no no i've got a bot and i got one
e4 so okay cool i think we are we are on
the way okay yeah money form and
if you look back at it now at those 12
games
of course arnold had six white games he
played three times e4 or three times d4
and
it's quite surprising actually if you
think about it he played uh those those
3d4 games
he played he won the last one yeah this
uh
with the help of this f3 system and
after that he laid only uh two games
with e4 it's quite quite surprising i
think that uh
he wouldn't uh wouldn't try d4 anymore
but okay
most likely had some some new ideas in
in store here
so um
we got the sicilian again so yeah gofund
sticks to his uh preparation
96 start of invitation for schresnikov
which is declined with the antics
version called bishop b5 this is the one
of the reasons i didn't like the
supposed nikov much anymore because
bishop b5 is what is all the theory
so this rosalimo
system
and now e6 again was chosen
now and again immediate exchange on c6
um
and then b takes
so this all happened
uh before
uh but now was this a different move d3
was this identical as well yeah d3 is
the new move for this match in um
game
10
the white game before that officially
played b3 yeah and was surprised by this
uh
yeah almost novelty e5
and now he went d3 which is i think the
main move
um the the idea of playing d3 here
and not castling for
for instance is to still have this h4
option which also
will be happening in the game
and well because very often if you look
at black setup here
he doesn't really want to play knight to
f6 but most often
he would go to g6 with this knight and
then this h4 idea
is really uh something to consider to to
try to kick this knight with h4 h5 yeah
so this is why i place d3 sort of um
yeah keeping these options open oh
that's very clever actually never
occurred to me he's waiting for this
just to kick the knight
leave the rook on each one that's that's
ingenious
so the beauty and excitement is all
behind the scenes
here in this game isn't it
yeah okay g3 is just a normal kind of
move um now so i'm not sure what played
97 yeah
and again another waiting move b3 so
well he can pounce on
g6 with bishop b72 now
but also he can pounce on knight g6 with
h4 currently now so
um
yeah i'm not sure if this bb3 move is
new or
it's most likely not a novelty but
it's uh i think um
i'm not quite sure i only saw this the
press conference with
sort of
yeah and um just one year so to say i
didn't listen to it
too closely because i was a bit a bit
sick about this uh this game um
so
okay yeah so um yeah i wasn't um d6 here
d6
so yeah aiming for that e5 that which we
discussed in the earlier game to get
that nice
center and you mentioned the idea that
one issue
is if white disrupts black's pawn
structure potentially and tries to
establish a foothold with e5 and that
was actually what was played e5 yeah
yeah this is uh almost
yeah
maybe
almost the only move that makes any
sense here
if black gets to play e65 he's
immediately fine yeah so white needs to
do this but it's uh yeah it's a pawn
sacrifice if if yeah if d takes i so you
you wouldn't play knight takes because
of
queen d4 i guess
that doesn't yeah that doesn't work
protecting
c6 right sorry it's nice hanging there's
no there's no amazing
bishop sacrifice here is this
that would just be bad um
no sometimes tricks and we i think we
discussed the similar line in uh yeah in
the last game but everything's also
hanging with check yeah the night hangs
with check and so on yeah so um
this uh
this wouldn't happen but uh white most
likely
would play some some other move instead
of taking on e5 maybe bishop b2 on
knight d2
some move to sort of
knight d2 it doesn't really threaten 95
because this pawn structure is quite
fragmented here
yeah but but f6 you know f6 it's not too
clear
um i mean they they of course would have
prepared this yeah it was all
played also very quickly by white so
it's clear that um this was preparation
so um
not sure i'm not so sure about bishop b2
because
does the bishop really do much now on b2
let's see all right after f6 yeah maybe
just queen
maybe queen and black e2 and then bishop
e3 to target c5 instead quick queen e2
maybe and then bishop e3
yeah and maybe maybe just just
bishop b2 is a kind of automatic move
that yeah or just bishop e3 and i've
seen adams
play in this system a move maneuver like
this that would hit
c5 as well this sort of queen maneuver
yeah they should be 3m but 95 i think oh
my goodness
you don't want to give both knights i
guess both bishops i guess
yeah it's not not easy to tell maybe
just see for them first and then bishop
e3
if that's technically oh you know f5
no i don't know
okay that's tricky
so uh
not quite sure i think there are
multiple options yeah also this bishop
be too it it's not necessarily bad um
it's just um
not quite clear how it would continue
one thing if you if you look at the
position d takes e5 bishop b2 f6 and
then imagine white castling rookie one
and then playing something like c3 and
d4 yeah like opening it up completely
this could be an idea also yeah and it's
it's a bit risky because black is really
uh behind in development so he he didn't
he didn't take but played a knight to g6
and yeah this is also quite a logical
move
to not get to too far behind in
development and again the pawn sacrifice
was repeated an invitation to win a pawn
with h4
just to fracture black's pawn structure
yeah and this was also played quickly so
it was uh
we discovered here uh well
what would white do and he just played
knight d2 here a pawn down but with a
fantastic potential
blockade
and pressure maybe not maybe
but more likely bishop e3 sometimes
especially if there's no knight to
pounce on the bishop bishop e3 to target
c5 later
yeah this is now uh
quite quite nice uh from a structure
point of view
so black has got two bishops but they're
both not doing doing so much
so much
especially the light squared bishop um
has got
yeah mostly one uh one function here to
just to uh to um yeah to exchange itself
or for a night which appears on c4 yeah
so it's uh it's interesting yeah by this
time at this point i thought okay maybe
we get an
really interesting um game here yeah
so uh but but now i think garfund
invested almost 30 minutes and then came
up with
quite um yeah i'm not quite sure how
surprising this move is
but
c4 yes
counter pawn sacrifice immediately
liberating the bishop across this
diagonal making wave potential c5s and
bishop b7s potentially as well
so it's just trying to get the dynamism
these pawns out of the way for the
bishops
and also this diagonal um
but this this diagonal can be used in
emergency now
but i've seen yeah we've seen this pawn
sacrifice in many recent
high-level games haven't we in this
variation i think i've seen a carrack in
game recently in this with a c4 yeah
sometimes it happens uh in a position
where
black has a pawn on d5 and then plays c4
but this is like just giving it away for
yeah but okay it's uh it's i guess um
guess a good move um because it
doesn't allow y to um get into this kind
of
locating strategy way it's got
everything under control
and now at least black can activate his
pieces
so if you look at the the course of the
game i think it's
most likely a good idea
so um
yeah i don't know thought for a while
and then took on form with a with a
knight
yes he did fight think for a while and
um
and i predicted actually um
well
i think everyone was predicting bishop
a6
and then queen f3 was prediction and
that came true here
just
seemingly
i thought it was with the intention of
queen d5 queen g3
with an interesting game to justify this
h pawn maybe and with pressure points
but unfortunately
unfortunately my expectation
was shattered here after queen d5 i
really didn't expect
what happened here which was
a queen exchange but it does win a pawn
um
for white to go pawn up but
queen g3 might be a viable a viable
alternative here what do you think about
that
yeah it's hard to tell
um i i didn't
i didn't really um see this
phase of the game because they had some
uh
art
documentary terry on and i was doing
some other stuff
so um
i'm not sure what what would black play
now
well the point is okay white white will
be a pawn up if he exchanges the queens
as he did white has an extra pawn but
it's really
also quite obviously questionable
if it's enough to really make something
out of this so this is of course
more ambitious at first sight
but
i'm not quite sure what would happen
g3
fictional variation which
amused me which would never happen but
imagine bishop c3 here bishop a3
this is just the fictional and i don't
think there's enough compensation here
it was just something i had briefly
amused myself with
but forget it it was it was bishop b4
might have been an idea as well but
white avoids this this whole thing
by by taking on d5 okay so
the complexity of the queen g3
uh
remaining mystery um unless you want to
have a quick look should we go on to the
game
it's it's of course also possibly um
dangerous for white yeah
it's uh
i think the the advantage of queen takes
d5 of course is
um that you're quite likely not to lose
the game yeah
and um this queen g3 is sort of still
playing for a win
yeah for three results yeah you you're
considering that you maybe could you
could maybe lose right so queen takes d5
is maybe the the kind of move
which
yeah is preferred in those kind of last
games
in a match but um
difficult really queen g3 i would also
consider the move e4 here
all right
and just this would be my first instinct
to
get rid of the double pawn and
maybe open up the position here but
it's difficult
maybe white can just castle it's an
interesting position it's certainly not
not immediately obvious that it uh
should be uh should be bad or anything
you should be forced also very well at
what you suggested first bishop before
to um get right to to move his king
yeah especially for hair
yeah this is interesting
and maybe the kind of stuff which would
get played maybe in this kind of rapid
games or
yeah those
i don't know less important games it's
um it's sort of risky but this is um
kind of the way this uh
whole match is progressing it's a very
risk averse
you imagine kf on maybe castle queenside
then what white cannot take on
well he has to protect g2 that'll be
disaster
that's not going to happen in just
fictional variation but
castling queenside actually maybe taking
on e5
um yeah i'm not sure yeah
oh no taking on e5 is not possible
uh
yeah it's this can easily easily
backfire on white so yeah
the queen on d5 is not a bad piece here
it's quite powerful yes hitting
g2 and
if black can castle queenside this
pressure on g7 might be an illusion so
maybe this is maybe this is the safe
this is the definitely
it's the safer choice just to take the
queens off
reduce the complexity of the positions
quite considerably yeah and you've got
to get an extra pawn after all you can
you can try in this position
rather than well actually they're both
that would be undoubling the pawns could
be taken anyway
so it's
but so black wants to get maybe the c
file
pressure yeah he needs to get something
on on c2 yeah
so he takes with a c pawn
okay white takes the extra pawn now
extra pawn up
but black and the commentator support
black would be doing fine here
with the two bishops i think bishop d6
was mentioned but actually
uh e5
um
was played
uh and then after
so here white castled
um i don't know what you think of e5 do
you think there are viable
alternatives um
to e5
yeah but yeah e5 looks quite quite
normal doesn't it i mean
is there some some issue with e5 um
not particularly
it's a white white castle now
and the king didn't need to manually um
automatically castle the king
uh just went to f7 here
uh so we've got so black has the bishop
pair
and potential for rook c8 but this c
file is about to be shut down by white
uh
it's awesome
it's always notoriously difficult to
to get your pawns your pawns rolling
against those bishops it's very
difficult
especially this uh a6 bishop which might
get to b7 and then on the long diagonal
yeah it's very annoying
i mean it's uh it's clearly um that it's
clear that black has
quite some compensation here yeah
so c4 trying to shut down the c file and
now just bishop e7
here just connecting rooks hello brooks
connected
so um
okay uh and offering well this pawn
can't be taken d3 would be horrible
right so it's not taken um
instead white plays bishop e3
eyeing a7 uh trying to restrict maybe
the rook for a moment
black definitely doesn't want to play
move like d4 bishop would just
that that wouldn't help bishops of black
to play d4
no no you can you can just keep the
tension here right
you can in this kind of positions you
can just just check
in terms of uh
yeah being equal not
playing for an advantage as black you
can even just need to check if white can
move any any of his pawns and he cannot
so um if as long as you keep him from
moving those pawns yeah you should you
should be very fine
and also there are also some some other
things like the king on f7 is
quite quickly on e6 and uh helping
um in the center and white has got the
king on g1 so
so bishop b7
here
and now white
did kind of expose the d3 pawn but black
is actually threatening
horrible things now um
like uh doubling here potentially d4
bishop f3 so actually c takes d5
was played
um
here
um
and after bishop takes e5 white quickly
went to the c file
with with rook fc one
so rook fc one here
and maybe some players would be
concerned about rook
c7
in this position
but in fact a5 was played um
so what do you think now about this
position after fc one
yeah i can i can yeah it's easy here
because
this part of the broadcast i was
watching and
um kromnik just stated um that a5 didn't
make any sense to him that he would have
played rook c8 oh really so if yeah i
said if the a5 rook c7 and y can try a
bit but it's okay it's a draw he was
pretty much sure that this would this
would be a very drawish position
but he thought that a5 would be somewhat
in somewhat uh yeah not not the most
accurate move
let's take a look at you're going to
lose a7 potentially but it doesn't
matter about that i suppose takes taking
a7 is bad is it
very bad
yeah at the end you've got rookie
and then bishop b3 oh
of course bishop moves maybe um i see oh
that's a backfire
you could end up suitably maybe slightly
worse
yeah
what can what can be very very quickly
worse it's just easy you blunder one
pawn you're really bad in this position
yeah so
also um this is this even loses two
pawns a2 is gone as well yeah
so in fact okay so a5
um
and now white just aimed to get
rid of black's bishop power with bishop
c5 and not mind this this doubling of
pawns
um
uh for the moment
black
he just actually indirectly targeted d3
now as if bishop f3
and d3 is targeting
um
and um unfortunately for the spectators
and everything um some were very
disappointed
on chess gamescom
and also disappointed that the world
championship match will now be decided
by rapid but unfortunately bishop takes
e7 and the draw was
agreed
um so some people blame that the match
is too short it should have been over 24
games
um i don't know what do you think it has
been a bit of um
there have been much more exciting world
championship matches in the past
well those people those people who won
24 games must be a bit maybe
i think the paradox
was was but maybe this is because of
engine preparation but let's try okay
let's quickly mention this this final
position how dry it is or otherwise so
we assume a recapture if they had played
on and what would be white's best move
here
yeah white's best move will be to just
play on and then let's let like show
what he has for the pawn
i mean if you give this to a computer it
will tell you really zero zero zero yeah
um
just zero um
immediately
um but uh
well
why not just play this on you've got a
pawn
and let's say knight d2 i play 92 rook
c3 and i just keep this pawn and okay
black might get it back but
it needs to be shown
um okay in the press conference i wish
he gave some some line which he thought
would be
totally drawn whatever
um i i don't uh don't know exactly what
this line was maybe
it is an issue yeah it is an issue but
it's just if you well i watched this
this part of the broadcast and and
kramnik was was absolutely shocked that
the game was over really he was shocked
yeah
yeah yeah completely i thought it was
was absolutely insane to to give it to
this to draw this position
because white cannot lose gaff and had
10 minutes arnold had 50 minutes yeah so
it's it's like uh and and and and gavin
was just sweating there you could you
could look at look at him and see oh
it's he wasn't so
so i was at this point i was pretty sure
that he would uh
be i don't know tortured for like two
hours or something maybe it is a draw
but white can can offer the draw anytime
and get it immediately what do you think
about knight e1 as an alternative
tonight
you can bring your king in and the
knight actually defends g2 as well as d3
maybe this is an alternative plan
um and then
yeah
possibly
the problem is a bit like this a4 move
also yeah
yeah
a4 and
a4 b4 a3 and the a2 pawn is quite weak
yeah
there are ideas i'm not i'm not arguing
that maybe black black can can draw this
anyway
but it's really from a practical point
of view um
impossible to offer a draw here i i
simply it simply makes no sense to me i
can guarantee you that absolutely if you
give this position to cards and he would
never offer a draw
never never in 100 years and for if to
if he plays 10 games
he would play win two or three of them
so with white you definitely favor white
with the extra pawn yeah maybe it is a
draw maybe some some people come up with
a line but why not let let why not let
it show me
it's quite uh
i was really sick that that they gave
when i don't mind those short draws if
there's nothing to play for but in the
light of a4 i mean these pawns are a
sitting target these three pawns for the
light square bishop potentially in the
and the rooks and
maybe you know so anand realizes he has
a huge superiority
in rapid chess statistically
yeah and he's been playing his moves a
lot quicker in this match
so maybe you know he welcomes the rapid
chess phase and both players kind of win
because
girlfriend doesn't lose credibility in
the long games that he held an end in
the long game match and if he loses the
rapid then he loses the rapid it's more
like um
you know a lottery
the rapid so he doesn't lose any
credibility does he um and also for
anand he just wants the rapid because he
knows he's got superiority
so they both kind of may be happy with
the result to get into the rapids yeah
yeah black black is certainly happy here
with the draw because he was just gifted
this half point for nothing
it's it's just absolutely insane to to
make a draw here okay look if you can
tell
me whatever you want
and sorry this kind of position it's
maybe a draw but
i would have white here and some player
with two thousand six hundred would
offer me a draw i would just decline
hang on hang on this one we cannot lose
let's have a quick blitz game or two
from this position then so you know
white and i'm playing black
five seconds of move
i'm going to go with this a4 fans i
quite fancy this for black go on
no
no seriously go on play move for white
what would you play knight e1 or knight
d2
okay
or just we'll just play a few moves as
an example then go back and maybe
okay let's let's let's try um okay
i need to think about this a bit
yeah of course it's not
it's um i think it is tricky because
very full as you mentioned
no it's i'm i'm absolutely
it
the computer analyzed this position and
and said it is it is completely equal
so
i don't doubt that uh but it's not it
doesn't make any sense to if you got 40
minutes extra on the clock why would you
offer a draw it doesn't make any sense
maybe this maneuver is attractive if you
can get that to block the bishop is that
is that one thing that attracts you
i just want to tease out what attracts
you about the white position it doesn't
seem very healthy pawn up
okay
yeah but if i can keep it i keep it yeah
um
what what can you do let me you could
you can try this knight e1 it's it's
very passive looking but so i play a4 as
you mentioned it looks it looks dynamic
a4 we're coordinating here
on these pawns
okay emily rook ab1
uh so i get a rook infiltration then i
take you're going to take yeah
i assume
you're weak yeah
i i guess
uh i suppose rook a2 doesn't really do
anything
hell what if what if i just pressurize
that pawn with
my jaw gotta be careful about rook c7s
haven't i
um
there are rook c7s you can also consider
just rook b2 and rook c2b1
it's just the pawn it might mean you you
might get it back you might
it's not it's not like you can play any
move and draw
you're right it's it's not
it's if someone watches this video gives
this into a computer it might show a
line which is completely equal
but here he had 40 minutes extra this
was move 22
and uh
girlfriend would have played it need to
play 18 moves in in 12 minutes it's not
a terrible time trouble but maybe there
are some things coming up and how should
white lose it's not possible it's not
possible for white to lose heart okay um
what could happen is i could lose a b3
pawn yeah and then i'll draw this
against anyone yeah really because that
it's nothing happening
um
yeah
it's
really maybe you're right and it's
completely drawn and everything's cool
but i don't think that that rishi really
wants i mean he doesn't mind the playoff
of course because that does he cannot do
anything and now to prevent it
but this is not like a regular rapid
game in in monaco where you play just
for money and basically it doesn't
matter if you do so win
um and um he can lose this title
uh with just one blunder in a rapid game
so
i'm not sure it's quite quite hard to
understand why uh why this should be
done
he's being the fastest gm ever he's been
playing
uh long games in his youth really really
quickly hasn't he
yeah sure and i don't i don't doubt that
he's the better rapid player but uh
it's still um a different situation
because um it's it's
it's um it's it's really much more at
stake than than usually it's more i
think a matter of
of your nerves then
then
the abilities and skill is of course
important but the nerves are very
important
and
you never know what what what might
happen there
yeah now if you would force me to bet
any money i would bid it on girlfriend
one hundred percent
let's put it because let's go back yeah
please maybe you're right then okay
maybe white
but maybe
but actually you know anand's been world
champion he's done that he's got the
t-shirt yeah so maybe the nerves are not
going to be as much as girlfriend yeah
he's you know
yeah
one thing what what one thing that is
absolutely
clear after this match that
we won't have any matches
anymore without
without anti-draw rules
because this is just acceptable i think
it's not acceptable
that out of um if they played 12 games
they had two decisive games you cannot
do much about
oh i mean i think i've got a fire alarm
going i think we're gonna have to cut it
short sorry i think there's some smoke
or something no it's stopped okay no
we're okay sorry house is not on fire
okay yeah the thing is they had 12 12
games two were decided and 10 draws i
mean the number of bosses
in in a way uh
not not too surprising but
you cannot really um i think tolerate
out of 10 drawn games that there are
nine games
around 25 moves
i guess yes i think a lot of people are
disappointed it wasn't most exciting you
know i think the most exciting world
championship match ever it seems to be
the 1972 match at the peak of the cold
war you know the political tensions
around the games because the media
really grabs hold of it you know being
centrally uh located at reykjavik
between the old you know ussr and states
the political tensions of the match you
know the match became more than a chess
match of course you have
those kind of matches are always uh
more interesting in a way
or spectacular if you have got really
two persons that are really completely
opposite to one another
and it doesn't really help
the the kind of
fighting
atmosphere of a match
if the two players are too friendly yeah
you know it uh it i think it's um
it fits both players personalities that
they after the game do a quick um
they often talk briefly about the game
and this is all very very nice but if
you
want to have a i know it's just more
spectacular and more interesting yeah if
if the players don't really like each
other or there are even political things
behind this yeah even if you just um
even um two years ago when anand played
to parlov it was all also a completely
different different thing yes yes
tension yeah atmosphere
okay um
all right um all right okay so we'll
we'll try and cover some of the rapid
games then shall we that those might be
really exciting you never know
uh when they come out wednesday yeah
maybe it's uh it's possible you never
know those uh the quicker time control
might uh
help both players to make some mistakes
and
and for once maybe uh they tried to play
a position out
the thing is i'm really this is really a
difference between
if you if you look at carlson's games
and these games i guarantee you those 10
draws
he would play on these positions and win
two of them
really those
is so tenacious and always goes on and
finds some things
that
that they need to solve over the board
and sometimes
they don't manage
even if
especially if the time gets a bit low
and so on
and uh somehow i'm a bit disappointed in
the
yeah i'm not sure if the fighting spirit
the right word but
just just to to to press on and and and
make and then pressurize the opponent
but are you sure actually the
temperature at the moment in both
england and germany is very very high
sure we're not just irritated by the
temperatures at the moment we're
experiencing as well
it's just you know sometimes we're
irritated if it's really hot it has been
really hot today and i haven't really
been in a mood to even play chess but
anyway i think i've got to go now before
i uh get in trouble so should we wrap it
up here chris and maybe carry on
wednesday
um yeah let's hope for for an
interesting uh playoff
we uh we had a playoff um
in
2006
already for the title and those games
were also very
very um
yeah very tense so
we can be
can be curious what what happens in the
tie break so
you can quote me uh i would bet on on
get on now
maybe uh at the end uh blimey
okay my favorite is actually anna and i
believe in his uh intuitive fast play so
i reckon he will win but okay we'll see
then on wednesday
all right um yeah
all right
okay um maybe i don't know maybe we can
do a live stream of the games as though
as they're being played i don't know if
you're around them when today maybe we
could try and do that yeah on wednesday
i mean first of all the game started
uh eight o'clock your time all right
it's a bit early sorry no maybe we're
not both okay we'll do them after
well i'm i'm at the office uh and need
to
earn some money okay
okay
um all right then um all right okay
until wednesday uh evening or whatever
okay um okay i hope some somebody got
anything on from this video on youtube
that'd be cool um all right see you
wednesday and uh okay um
comments or questions on both our
youtube channels
boy cheers